Salut ! Aujourd'hui je devais vous donner les résultats de l'expérience mentale "mouton/chèvre".
En fait je vous ferai cette vidéo là, lundi.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il s'est passé quelque chose
d'incroyable aujourd'hui.
Et il fallait absolument que je vous en parle.
Petite parenthèse également, j'ai vu que Pierre avait son nouveau compteur lui aussi.
Je crois qu'il y a une mode des compteurs qui commence à se lancer...
A la différence que moi je n'ai pas pris
7 plots pour mettre les chiffres,
puisque ça, ça vaut pour les 1 million d'abonnés.
On y est clairement pas...
Bon... Mais ce n'est pas le sujet de la vidéo !
Le sujet de la vidéo c'est ce petit trophée que vous voyez là-bas. Ici. Je vous emmène le voir.
[compteur qui se met en route]
Mise à jour !
Alors ici c'est donc le trophée que j'ai reçu
pour les 100 000 abonnés.
Voilà. Le "play".
"Fabien Olicard"
"Pour les 100 000 abonnés", "YouTube"...
C'était super ouf de le recevoir.
Je l'ai reçu lors du Meet Up que j'ai fait le 12 octobre dernier au Youtube Space à Paris.
Et c'est eux qui se sont occupés de l'avoir.
Je me suis dis: "Est-ce que c'est possible de hacker YouTube ou de hacker Google"...
C'est-à-dire, que, au bout d'un moment,
au bout de 8 semaines je crois,
j'ai eu une petite barre bleue...
On me demandait mon adresse, sur YouTube.
Donc je l'ai remplie.
Et j'ai reçu un petit coli aujourd'hui...
Donc là-bas, vous pouvez le voir, il y a le trophée.
Et ici, il y a la boite !
Et si on ouvre la boite...
On s'aperçoit qu'à l'intérieur, il y a la lettre.
La fameuse lettre, qui me félicite.
Merci beaucoup !
C'est très gentil Susan !
C'est Susan !
Susan, je ne souhaite pas prononcer
votre nom de famille...
Excusez-moi !
Une jolie mousse protectrice.
Et sous cette mousse protectrice...
OH ! Dis donc !
Un trophée des 100 000 abonnés !
[rires]
Que je vais sortir tout de suite !
Le découvrir !
[Ton ironique]
J'en ai jamais vu d'aussi près.
Un magnifique trophée...
Voilà...
Avec les félicitations, et...
Et là, là vous vous dites forcément :
on n'a pas vu encore les deux trophées
en même temps,
au même endroit.
Donc si ça se trouve, il est en train de nous faire
une vidéo complétement putaclic,
il n'a pas du tout les deux trophées...
Alors je vais le poser ici.
Et puis je vais aller chercher le deuxième !
Voilà, je l'ai, je l'ai de caché.
Alors attention !
Est-ce que cette vidéo est un fake ou pas ?!
Est-ce que j'ai vraiment deux trophées ou pas ?!
Et bien oui !
J'ai deux trophées !
[rires]
Pardon YouTube !
Pardon YouTube...
Ça a été un petit problème
dans votre système en interne.
Et... et... je ne voulais pas faire ça.
[rires]
Mais j'ai les deux trophées.
Du coup je me dis aussi
comme j'ai passé les 300 000 abonnés,
est-ce que je vais avoir un troisième trophée
pour les 100 000 abonnés ?
Ou pas ?
C'est une question comme ça...
Et après si un jour j'en ai 10...
Je vous échange les 10 contre le trophée du million.
[rires]
On peut faire ça !
Alors oui !
Comme je vous disais,
on voit de plus en plus de compteurs
comme le mien dans les vidéos sur YouTube,
mais je ne suis pas sûr qu'on voit de plus en plus de trophées dans les vidéos YouTube.
Mais dans les miennes, celles qui sont faites
ici chez moi, il y aura les deux.
[chuchotant]
Pardon YouTube !
Voilà, on est clairement sur une vidéo
qui n'a rien à voir avec ce que je fais d'habitude,
mais je trouvais ça important
de partager ce moment là avec vous.
Maintenant je vais y aller parce que ce soir
je fais une représentation au Trianon.
Euh...
Ce week-end je suis à Brignoles
c'est déjà complet,
la semaine prochaine à Aix-en-Provence
il reste 20 places en tout sur les 5 jours
En février je serai également à Toulon,
à Grenoble et à Versailles.
Versailles ce sera la date la plus proche de Paris
sur ces 6 mois de tournée.
Et puis il y a tout le reste des dates de tournée sur le site, dont le lien est dans la description !
Allez je vous donne rendez-vous lundi.
Lundi matin ou lundi soir ?
Peut-être plus lundi soir, hein...
pour les résultats de l'expérience mentale.
C'est peut-être mieux de voir ça le soir,
dites moi, pareil, dans les commentaires.
Si vous préférez que ce soit le matin ou le soir...
Peut-être que je vais mettre un petit sondage là,
quelque part, au-dessus, soyez très attentif.
Bon, si le fait d'avoir réussi à avoir deux trophées
ça vous a fait marrer,
n'oubliez pas de laisser un pouce en l'air
et de vous abonner !
Et rendez-vous lundi matin...
ou soir,
pour enfin le résultat de l'expérience mentale !
Les résultats sont un peu ouf.
A bientot !
Ciao !
[musique générique de fin]